we've talked about the idea of standard
form of a linear equation in other
videos and the point of this video is to
clarify something and resolve some
differences that you might see in
different classes in terms of what
standard form is
so everyone agrees that standard form is
generally a linear equation where you
have some number times x plus some
number times y is equal to some number
so things that are in standard form
would include things like 3x plus 4 y
is equal to 10
or
2 x
plus 5 y is equal to
negative 10. the everyone would agree
that these are standard form and
everyone would agree that the following
are not standard
standard form
so if i were to write
3x is equal to negative 4y
plus 10. even though these are
equivalent equations this is just not in
standard form similarly if i wrote that
y is equal to
3 times x plus 7 this is also not in
standard form
now the place where some people might
disagree
is if you were to see something like
6 x
plus 8 y
is equal to 20.
now why would some folks argue that this
is not standard form
well for some folks they would say
standard form the coefficients on x
and y and our constant term so our a b
and c can't share any common factors and
here 6 8 and 20 they are all divisible
by 2. and so
some folks would argue that this is not
standard form and to get it into
standard form you would divide all of
these by two and if you did you would
get this equation here now that's useful
because then you only have one unique
equation but on khan academy we do not
restrict in that way and that is also a
very popular way of thinking about it we
just want you to think about it in this
form a x plus b y is equal to c
when you do the exercises on khan
academy it's not going to be checking
whether the whether these coefficients a
b and c are divisible have a common have
a common factor so
for khan academy purposes this is
considered standard form although don't
be surprised if you encounter some folks
who say no
we would rather you remove any common
factors
now another example
would be something like
negative 3x minus 4y is equal to
negative 10.
so some folks would argue that this is
not standard form because they want to
see this first coefficient right over
here the a being greater than 0 while
here it is less than 0.
for our purposes on khan academy we do
consider this standard form
but i'm just letting you know because
some folks might not because this
leading coefficient is not greater than
zero
now another example that some people
might be on the edge with would be
something like
1.25 x
plus
5.50 y is equal to
10.5
and the reason why some people might not
consider this standard form is that a
b and c are not integers some folks
would say to be in standard form a b and
c need to be integers and you could
multiply both sides of the equation by
some value that will give you integers
for a b and c
but for khan academy purposes we do
consider this to be in standard form and
we think this is important actually not
just being able to have non-integers as
a b or c but also being able to have a
negative a right over there this
negative 3 is our a and also having
coefficients having our a's b's and c's
having shared factors we think all of
that's important because sometimes the
equation itself has meaning when you
write it that way and we'll see that
when we do when we do some word problems
when we actually go into real life and
we try to construct equations and based
on the information the equation it's
easier to understand if you keep it in
this form so for khan academy purposes
this is all standard form but it's good
to be aware in your mathematical lives
that some folks might want to see the
restriction of no common factors between
a b and c that a is greater than 0 and
that a b and c need to all be integers
but khan academy does not hold you to
that